you sit in your seat read joe biden's
staff prepared card today you sit in
your seat apparently ron claim was
worried biden was going to sit in
someone else's seats they put in all
caps you sit in your seat
all right
thank you mr president well the january
6 committee has investigated an
insurrection in washington the
insurrection but what's interesting is
there's been no investigation of any
kind into an actual insurrection that
happened two years ago in may of 2020.
a mob set fire to a historic episcopal
church right outside the white house and
they injured more than 60 secret service
officers as they tried to storm the
white house grounds now donald trump was
inside so the media applauded it
and so the siege the white house
continued all month on june 22nd of 2020
that was two years ago this week the mob
tried to tear down the andrew jackson
statue in lafayette square right in
front of the white house do you remember
this no one else seems to here's the
footage
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
raises a lot of questions like where
were the police they had ropes around
the statue right in front of the white
house and no one was doing anything
about it
there's a lot of blame to go around for
that by the way a lot
but that's not an insurrection
well not if no one remembers it even
happened and that's why that footage has
been memory hold you probably haven't
seen it in the last two years
that's because what's happening in
congress right now is not about an
insurrection it's about using the
mechanics of the federal government
which you pay for
especially the intel and law enforcement
agencies to crush and silence anyone who
opposes the democratic party joe biden
that's not an overstatement
one of the political opponents the
january 6 committee is targeting as a
man called jeff clark he was assistant
attorney general during the previous
administration
before dawn on wednesday which is say
yesterday a large group of armed federal
agents wearing body armor with weapons
raided jeff clark's home
they dragged him into the street in his
pajamas now what did jeff clark do wrong
was he selling fentanyl was he human
trafficking on the mexican border no
jeff clark did not commit any crime what
he did wrong was calling for an
investigation into voter fraud
we are happy to have jeff clark join us
now he's a senior fellow at the center
for renewing america
jeff thanks so much for joining us this
is uh
almost i mean this is a soviet account
really so tell us what happened and why
it is and good to be here uh tucker so
yesterday at about just before 7 a.m
there was loud banging at uh my door
insistent banging so i just rushed down
as fast as i could i
you know quickly figured out you know
that there were agents there i opened
the door and asked for the courtesy to
be able to put some pants on uh and was
told no you got to come outside so
i came outside they swept the house
eventually they let me go back inside
and uh put the pants on but then you
know by my count at one point uh you
know 12 agents and two uh fairfax county
police officers uh went into my house uh
searched it for three and a half hours
they even brought along something tucker
i've never seen before or heard of a
electronic sniffing dog
and they took all of the electronics
from my house uh and uh you know i i
don't blame the the agents i think it
you know what you're talking about in
terms of weaponization is really about
who's pointing the agents and telling
them what to do tucker
so peter strzok who worked at the fbi is
effectively a criminal in my view never
really punished sent out a tweet today
mocking you and gloating over the fact
that the bide administration stole your
cell phone and will now be reading all
of your private messages i mean at what
point can we say the department of
justice where you once served
is a political instrument it's
completely out of control
yeah i think this is highly politicized
and
it's also part uh tucker uh if you
didn't know it of a nationwide effort
yesterday there were multiple states
where multiple people were roughly
simultaneously uh you know rated for
their electronic devices uh and that
obviously requires a high level of
coordination and look um with the
hearing uh that was pointed at me and
and targeting me today uh with uh you
know the the uh special audience member
of sean penn so you know this is
hollywood uh you know that the very next
day you know it it looks highly
coincidental and tucker you know i just
don't believe in coincidences
so you know chris ray of course who runs
fbi you probably know merrick garland
he's been around washington a long time
both of them have decided to pervert and
corrupt our most basic institutions on
behalf of joe biden did you think they
were capable of doing that when you
worked there
i argued in front of merrick garland i
got a very uh respectful hearing i think
i was going to win that case but we
wound up actually uh settling it in the
shadow of what you know everyone assumed
was going to be a victory sometimes that
happens in financial cases and chris
wray was with me in the justice
department he was just in the criminal
division back in bush 43. so i do uh
know both of them and you know i i just
think we're living in a in an era that i
don't recognize and increasingly uh
tucker i don't recognize the country
anymore with these kinds of stasi-like
things happening
yeah this is stalinist at some point
somebody's going to fight back and it's
going to get super ugly i pray that
doesn't happen but i think it probably
will which is very the whole thing is so
sad and i'm sorry that you were caught
up in it in your pajamas like they could
have just called you it's outrageous
jeff clark i appreciate your coming on
we i hope you'll come back and tell us
where this winds up creeps
thank you